in the past few months I've been
traveling for weeks at a time with only
one suitcase of clothes one day I was
invited to an important event and I
wanted to wear something specially new
for it so look through my suitcase and I
couldn't find anything to wear I was
lucky to be the technology kind of
friend said that day and had access to
3d printers so quickly design a skirt on
my computer and I loaded the file on the
printers just printing the pieces
overnight the next morning I just took
all the pieces assembled it together in
my hotel room and this is actually the
dress shirt that I'm wearing right now
so it wasn't the first time that I
printed clothes for my senior collection
at Fashion Design School I decided to
try and 3d print an entire fashion
collection from my home the problem was
that I barely knew anything about 3d
printing and I had only nine months to
figure out how to print five fashionable
looks
I always felt most creative when I
worked from home I loved experimenting
with new materials and I always try to
develop new techniques to make the most
unique textiles from my fashion projects
I loved going to old factories and weird
stores in search of leftovers of strange
powders and weird materials and then
bring them on to experiment on as you
can probably imagine my roommates didn't
like that at all
so I decided to move on to working with
big machines once they didn't fit in my
living room
I loved the exact and the custom work I
can do with all kinds of fashion
technologies like knitting machines and
laser cutting and still printing once on
my break I came here to New York for an
internship at a fashion house in
Chinatown we worked in two incredible
dresses that were 3d printed
they were amazing like you can see here
but I had a few issues with them there
were made from hard plastics and that's
why they were very breakable the models
couldn't sit with them and they even got
scratched from the plastics under the
arms with 3d printing the designers had
so much freedom to make the dresses look
exactly like they wanted but still they
were very dependent on a big and
expensive industrial printers that were
located in a lab far from their studio
later the rear frame gave me a 3d
printed necklace printed using a home
printer I knew that these printers are
much more cheaper and much more
accessible than the ones we use at my
internship so look at the necklace and
then I thought if I can print a necklace
from home why not print my clothes from
home too I really like the idea that I
wouldn't have to go to the market and
pick fabrics as someone else chose to
sell I could just design them and print
them directly from home I found a small
maker
space where I learned everything I know
about 3d printing right away they
literally gave me the key to the lab so
I could experiment into the night every
night the main challenge was to find the
right filament for printing clothes with
so what is a filament filament is the
material you feed the printer with and I
spend a month or so experimenting with
PLA which is a hard and Scratchy
breakable material the breakthrough came
when I was introduced to Phil flex which
is a new kind of filament it's strong
yet very flexible and with it I was able
to print the first garment the rad
jacket that had the word Liberty freedom
in French embedded into it I chose this
word because I felt so empowered and
free when I could just design a garment
for my home and then printed by myself
and actually you can easily download
this jacket and easily change the word
to something else for example your name
or a Sweetarts name so the printer plays
our small side to piece all the garment
together just like a puzzle and I wanted
to solve another challenge I wanted to
print textile that I would use just like
a regular fabrics that's when I found an
open source files from an architect to
design a pattern that I love and with it
I was able to print a beautiful textile
that I would use just like a regular
fabric and it actually even looks a
little bit like lace so I took his file
and I modified it and change it play
with it many kind of versions out of it
and I needed to print another fifty nine
hundred more hours to complete printing
my collection so I brought six printers
to my home and just print it 24/7 and
this is actually a really slow process
but let's remember the internet was
significantly slower twenty years ago so
3d printing will also accelerate and in
no time you'll be able to print a
t-shirt in your home in just a couple of
hours or even minutes so you guys you
want to see how it looks like
so Rebecca is wearing one of my five
outfits almost everything here she is
wearing I print it from my home even our
shoes are printed Thank You Rebecca
thank you guys so I think in the future
material will evolve and they will look
in Felix fabrics we know today like
cotton or silk imagine personalized
clothes it fits exactly to your
measurements so music was once a very
physical thing you would have to go to
the record shop and buy CDs but now you
could just download the music digital
music directly to your phone fashion is
also a very physical thing and I wonder
how our world will look like when our
clothes will be digital just like
discourteous
thank you so much
you